he's cutting it close
kind of real i got real [ __ ] nervous
i was rushing to finish my [ __ ] so that
i could get in here because i got real
[ __ ] nervous about that's good not as
close it's 959
yeah that's what i'm saying they said it
was 55. no
i mean i'm telling you right when it
turns 10.
we roll
well okay we're rolling now but it's
only 9 59 don't make any sudden
okay all right because i did hear him
around
he he might be standing outside and
waiting
oh do you think this is no good no okay
all right let's go it's ten o'clock it
is it is officially ten o'clock that's
when we said we were going to do the
weekend i did i did see charlie here
earlier oh my god wow he's in the
building he's in the building he's in
you said he was in the kitchen yeah he
was you saw him tinkering around in the
kitchen yeah yeah oh boy he was making
oh he he had no regard for our time
whatsoever he was just making himself a
bagel just making a bagel with no regard
for when we said we were needed to be
here to record and i think in his mind
he's like well i'm in the office but the
office is not the room where we podcast
right now should we make oh and here he
comes he's coming he's late
no he did no he did that
he's got that this guy i saw that you've
been here forever
he just jammed food down his face so
fast to get in here on time you need a
whole bagel in the last two minutes did
you yeah he did i watched him pull it
out like a minute and a half ago it's
already hard enough for the body to die
he's gonna be late and he was but he was
really only if we're being fair he was
about 55 seconds later he did it for the
podcast well actually i'll tell you
there's two things i was like did we say
10 30 we see said ted
and i was looking i was like it's almost
10 but i was like it's probably better
if i just stroll in after 10 so they
they got something to talk about but
but let's talk about the bigger issue
here oh [ __ ] let's talk about parking
let's talk about parking
[Music]
well you got my you got my text right um
i did get your text all right so it's
obscene when charlie was able to pull
off yeah i'm sure well you know for
those of you who heard the last podcast
where we went on and on and on about
parking and how close one needs to park
to a column
charlie went and parked
so dangerously close to the column today
that i i was nervous that he possibly
scratched his car i'm literally behind
the column and my
my right wheel did touch the touch the
column and that's when i was like okay
that's close enough i'll park yeah my
god
yeah i don't believe no i want to
believe that it went one of two ways and
either way is amazing the first way
that i want to believe is that you
backed that thing up at like 55 and
slammed on the brakes and just stopped
and got out now that didn't happen but i
like to believe that it did because it
would have been cool yeah like in a full
in a full slide
yes i dressed i drifted in i'd say
the other version is you getting out
over and over and over again and
checking to make sure how close you can
get it which i don't think is what
happened either but i like the idea of
thinking you kept getting out and kept
looking at it and
i'm inching it [ __ ] put it right on
top of it i was switching it
i did it in two moves
so there were no other cars in the
garage that made it a lot easier yeah
but i came in
i tossed the tail back at
far at an extreme end extreme angle all
right
all right that's really good that's
actually a good technique no the way i
parked is ridiculous i don't know that's
absurd i only know what i'm saying for
this conversation i'm sure no it was
clear that was clear yeah i'm i'm
genuinely worried about getting out like
that's going to be as long as you pull
forward your wheel's already turned you
should be in good shape you kept your
wheel turned which was smart so that the
butt went in first i'm like oh that's
hilarious i'm behind the pole awesome
and then i was thinking about it before
i came in and i'm like i can't wait to
get in there and just yeah the most
[ __ ] do the most ridiculous parking
so close and then
and then i was able to yeah turn the
wheel in until i felt the wheel hit the
pole i was like perfect
great yeah i'm in i think i would have
been willing to scratch my car for the
joke
yeah i know you would i know you would
and i and i appreciate that about you
you're willing to go that far for a good
joke yeah no that's not i know because
they're gonna be i don't understand the
technology here is there gonna be a
possibility for people to go to some
sort of site that we could we could put
the photos up because i think i think
the photos will tell the real story here
now listen guys a story of uh because
glenn did a park job yesterday that was
obscene yeah it seemed it was it was a
shot across the bow he's going to claim
he always do i do that i do and i'm
going to i'm going to say he went the
extra maybe you you think that you do
but you don't you never go that tight no
i do i swear to god i am with you i am a
maniac i am an absolute maniac and
because you know that but we don't know
that it extends specifically to parking
it does because
because it bothers me so much when
people don't get close
i i put it upon myself to get so
obscenely close to the column every
single time
uh and have done for many years uh
that's just how i am i'm i'm i'm i'm a
maniac yeah i'm an absolute maniac now i
want to say hold on so i parked next to
you today charlie um
and i i'm gonna i want to get out ahead
of this okay
i purposely didn't park too close to the
wall this time because i didn't need to
there's a full
like almost a full car width between our
cars you could squeeze a garbage truck
in there so i was like there's no point
in me getting too close to the wall
because we've both got so much room just
i could swing my door open
now wait a second that's disrespectful
to the person that could come in after
charlie let's just say charlie had to
leave early he doesn't
you he might no he does actually i do
[Laughter]
yeah
i'm still within the line and i'm still
parked very close to the wall to be
clear okay i'm just not as absurdly
close as i would normally get okay yeah
well guys
we've settled it uh charlie wow well no
no this is an ongoing saga yeah i mean
i'm not going to park like that again uh
i don't think you should
i don't think you should get that no
that's a comedy park job yeah it was a
good job it was great it was a good bit
yeah um i genuinely enjoyed this episode
100 baby yeah um i remember we had a lot
of fun writing it i remember us thinking
that we were sort of like tapping into
some new [ __ ] with this particular
episode i think there's no issue
of uh surrounding this episode you know
what i mean it's just like i don't even
know one thing i don't and the only one
thing that i
whatever we got into a uh
into a thing with it we used it a bunch
and it when it worked for the show but
it dates the show is like the parody
aspect of it because we all saw that
movie right over 100
million dollar baby and it was probably
either that year the right that they won
an oscar and we were like what the [ __ ]
is what is this movie yeah why do people
like this why did people even like this
movie it was terrible it was terrible
it's terrible no offense to all the
people who who made that movie except
well i haven't gone back maybe i'd see
it again and like it was you know i
don't know maybe it was terrible to
someone in their 20s and in your 40s
you're watching you're like oh well it
was like a boxing movie that you'd seen
before except this time like it was just
a feat from it was a woman and she was
great she that's what i was going to say
hilary swank's performance she's
of course she's she's great but then but
then the end not spoiling anything
because the movie's been out for 20
years in the end she just rando randomly
gets paralyzed in in the ring very
similarly
yeah yeah
yeah
um
by the way your memory of the writing of
that
is misinformed okay we had a very
difficult time writing that one
and i remember that you guys wanted to
throw it out at a certain point you were
like this just this isn't gonna work
let's just chuck it and i remember
thinking okay i do see something that we
can do to connect these stories they
just weren't feeling connected i don't
remember what that thing was remember
doing a pass and then you guys be like
okay yeah that could work and then we
jump back into it but i remember at one
point we were like this one isn't going
to work
it does seem that it's
the first time where we got started to
get really cartoonish we did a montage
our first montage
maybe yeah uh no because we did a
montage and charlie has cancer but oh
right yeah
the reason i say it's cartoonish is that
we we got you guys like hooked on to
some kind of steroid which then
almost immediately turned you into like
animals like legitimately two episodes
before with christmas it's one of the
first time no but you know what it is
but that is what crack would do
well i don't know from steroids rob why
don't you tell us about the steroid use
yeah
why don't you go into that i'm happy to
walk you through it you guys won't do a
whole episode about steroids but you
know i'm very interested in the email
cycle for that no i'm sure i'm sure dak
shepard's got that that area covered
yeah
yeah you guys all you just your
obsession with male bodies
yeah cartoonish
like i i am i wrong in thinking like
we started
doing like bits in this episode i don't
recall us really doing like bits before
this like
for instance i remember the one of the
first times i had trouble getting
through a scene was in this when we were
shooting the scene where we're massaging
where i'm massaging charlie yeah
and i i remember i was like uh something
clicked for me there where i was like oh
this is really funny to me and it was
and it's such a stupid little bit
and something clicked for me there and
we started doing i think started doing
more things that were just like you know
what i don't know why this is funny it's
just funny it's funny behavior funny
human behavior [ __ ] there's a weird
balance in that episode between the
really broad stuff like weightlifting
jokes or shaving your face or whatever
and uh
and then yeah the much more subtler like
well like you know just like what type
of wood it is that i punched yes right
that conversation yeah that kind of
enjoyed those
i enjoyed those conversations so much
exactly exactly like the clown baby bit
too i remember do you know where that
came from
do you remember where that came from
i'm gonna i'm gonna suggest that i
remember and may and maybe you and i'm
gonna i'm gonna lay this out and maybe
i'm dead wrong but i i i distinctly
remember having a conversation
where charlie was like i don't
i feel like in every episode we're
taking my character to a cartoonish
place where he's this like baby clown
clown baby and like i don't want to
[ __ ] do that i don't want to be a
clown baby and we were like
okay i unders we understand that but
it's also really funny and like maybe
it's telling me not not to want to be a
clown i think it was just like you are
absolutely right i totally remember that
yeah 100
it was you describing yourselves as
being like a like a clown yeah yeah like
a dumb clown baby
and then that sticking with us and being
like clown babies just funny and then
when we got to that episode we were like
ooh i think you know also from
a running joke about a really funny
email
yeah yeah clown baby dot fart climbing
nose clown penis
penis that's from snl which is an snl
thing yes
i'm i'm almost 100 that you you were
like well it wasn't that you were
unwilling to go to places it was just
like ah i feel like i'm turning into a
cartoon character
yeah and then and then it turned into
clown baby and then we put that in the
show and then you were by far the
funniest in the show and then we were
like well let's just all be clown babies
oh let's all be clowns which we
eventually got yeah yeah except me and
then we're like no then we both dialed
you back you dialed me back yeah try to
reign me and give [ __ ]
i stole a major bit from you in this
episode uh what is it you might have
even actually suggested that i steal it
because it was a probably your pitch and
it's to me it's really funny but in the
first season when we did the nazi
episode right uh you thought it was
going to be really funny if we
if when i opened the door to reveal you
wearing the knife oh the banana you were
casually eating this banana
right which was really funny and then in
this second yeah you came up with that
on the day as i recall that wasn't in
the script you were just like it'd be
funnier if i'm just like doing something
very kind of the dumbest food possible
really yes yes okay so then the in this
episode this guy sounds so intrigued me
this this charlie guy this charlie guy
yeah what else does he do and then in
this in this episode
you you would have been behind the
monitors so you would have either
suggested it or i would have just
straight up
i would have said i'm just going to
steal this from you and then it was the
reveal that we're at this at this event
and we're just casually eating i'm just
yeah just a brutal underground fighting
uh situation like a you know real blood
sport kind of a thing yeah so i'm sure
fans looked at that and they were like
oh it's like a running thing where these
guys are casually eating food when they
have these like very s but really it's
just me stealing well no but that is
what that was the idea behind it was
like we thought that was funny we're
like no that is funny it's funny to be
in a situation like this and just be
casually eating the dumbest possible
food um i think to our credit none of us
have ever cared about that stuff you
know it's like hey man that's my joke
like that that would have been a toxic
environment for creating something like
okay i did something that's funny if you
do it and it's funny when in the next
scene when you're doing it great yeah
yeah i mean there's i'm sure there's a
line where like you know a a line that
could be crossed where like if i you
know i literally started doing every
[ __ ] funny thing that you ever did
until it's like fully made it my persona
that would probably be pretty irritating
but it'll also be bad acting on my part
i've heard us do it like we do a take
someone does an improv two takes later
someone else is doing is already taking
the line and it's like unconscious yeah
yeah yes that is true that does happen
yeah yeah yeah that's a little
irritating
we knew a lot we had a lot of friends in
this in this episode like we knew a lot
a lot of friends
that's pretty much how we were casting
things but i mean this one is like i
mean like jason van over
uh who's my buddy from college who
played the guy who mugs us in the alley
in the beginning and in the end
jessie ward jesse ward who i also knew
from when i was in college although she
was next door um at the school of
american ballet
so i've known her for
years
um
katie chrysler who plays the
uh the drug dealer who gets uh these
steroids for her she also went to
college talking about cartoon though the
choice to reveal her popping up and i
was saying like that like
do you remember in in the script do you
remember what it said in the script i
remember this she came out from the chat
she came and she emerged from the
shadows and they were like i remember
that too we don't have the capability to
create [ __ ] you can't make a shadow yes
yeah that requires uh 100
and then she says at the end let's lurk
back into the shadows so we were like
well we're going to get it in the
dialogue yeah but there is no shadow to
lurk into no there are no she just
popped up no isn't that funny like you
know nowadays
if we came to sat you know and
they lit the scene they're like yeah so
we couldn't come up with a shadow we'd
be like sorry go make a shadow and then
we'll we'll shoot we'll shoot with a
shadow what are you talking about unless
unless it was gonna add half an hour to
our day in which case we'd go it's
probably fine if she just pops up right
which is probably what we did
is saying that yeah we don't really need
a shadow
you just never ever pop up into the
frame guys we've rented this gym for two
hours so we gotta shoot all these scenes
so let's uh let's talk about eddie mecca
sure well another another great friend
great friend of danny's if i recall oh
god no that's hard to tell whether danny
genuinely hated that guy or if he was
just in character i think that's
something that danny does like sometimes
if the character's gonna be really upset
danny will stay a little bit upset yeah
but then i i can't tell if he starts to
become upset because he's been acting
upset and it's affecting him or if eddie
mecca was just annoying his [ __ ] out of
dan either way those scenes are great
that guy is hilarious he's [ __ ]
hilarious he's great and do you guys
remember
that okay so when he has the line uh pan
you know don't get your panties in an
uproar that wasn't written that was not
written the line that we wrote don't get
your panties in a bunch or a twist i
don't remember if it was a twist or a
bunch either way it was yeah it was the
he was in an uproar and he was yes he he
in a take or or in the rehearsal i don't
remember what it was he just went up on
the line and mixed his metaphors oh did
he go up on it and that's right it's so
much better benny's in an uproar panties
yeah don't yeah exactly don't get your
panties in an uproar is one of my
favorite things anyone said in this show
ever then we went to him after that take
or the rehearsal or whatever it was that
he said it and we said
eddie you accidentally said don't get
your panties in an uproar that's the
line now yeah that is now the line and
so that became the line in every other
take let me ask you about this about
this episode
the final sequence the slow motion
sequence did we shoot that on film yes
we should we shot that with the phantom
camera so no it wouldn't have been did
we have the phantom for that yeah are
you sure because why are the lights
blinking why because it's so [ __ ]
because we shot it on whatever we shot
it on those lights started strobing yes
but i don't think we shot it on film i
thought we should we shot it with that
phantom which was like the first
super high speed camera i should look
into that yeah i remember that the first
time we used the phantom was in the
christmas episode
it could be which means maybe we shot
this with film but that wouldn't have
created that strobing thing i don't know
what yeah i'm not sure what we do i
don't know we shot it with something
different which is because we couldn't
slow down our cameras to yeah slow
enough to get to get it to look how we
wanted to look but
i remember it was film i remember in the
editing room we tried a lot of different
music choices for that and then when we
came across moonlight sonata yeah i
remember i remember you know we weren't
totally sure we're like this is a little
felt like um heavy yeah yeah yeah it
felt heavy and maybe a little yeah right
like normally we would we would compose
or we would put something very light in
such a heavy moment right again
something about it that just was so
disturbing and beautiful
and i couldn't by the way i had to cover
my eyes when she when she i can't watch
it when she breaks her neck it's
upsetting i i really can't watch it
how do we do
that did we get a reverse
we would not have been sophisticated
enough to do that
but dan addis might have yeah yeah so we
probably did that in reverse yeah no
i don't know i don't know how do you do
that i could ask jesse someone pulls her
up
yeah i don't you would have seen her arm
go up yeah i think she went down i think
she did it really slowly maybe yeah
i think someone held her arm and oh man
we pulled her up maybe maybe
god because if we could remember things
i will i will ask we remember enough you
remember most things i'm upset you can't
remember this is it film
yeah or is it some sort of phantom
camera yeah
or is it a phantom camera is it a
phantom camera though okay let's let's
put that on either way it looks terrible
it looks terrible
strobing guys come on
meg has a no uh a note here please talk
about the background actor in the gym
who's holding the towel and keeps
looking at the camera craig
that guy was great yes i mean well he
wasn't he wasn't he wasn't he wasn't and
that's why it was so fun yeah he was he
was um he was great but not probably for
the reasons that he thought um i think i
don't know what was going through his
head but
the the absolutely bewildered look on
his face was by the way why we put him
in that role because we wanted some guy
i just think the name craig is funny i
apologize to all the craigs out there
but i just think the name craig is funny
we named him craig
uh he's just uh he's eddie mc he's bobby
thunderson's lackey
and he's just always standing behind him
leering and
meg's right he just was we couldn't get
him to stop looking into the [ __ ]
camera that's the guy you're talking
about right yeah yeah he was so like
nervous and
yeah you know
yeah he didn't know what he was doing no
he was not an actor no he was he was was
he an extra sorry was he i think he was
an extras casting that would just grab
we said you got a funny look go and yeah
and then he might be one of the better
things of the episode yeah just a man
who constantly looks like
uh he's worried that he's either that he
doesn't know whether he's doing the
right thing that's a little bit of a
rip-off of the guy in big lebowski who's
with john tuttoro uh yes totally
yeah the the the the um he's got like a
bowling lackey yeah the guy with the the
the um the military haircut that kind of
overweight guy with the mustache who's
been in like also a million movies
really yeah always just playing like
somebody in the background or has like
one line or something that guy yeah i
know exactly who you're talking about
yeah
but that's a good bit too
uh
do you remember where the uh the line i
will eat your babies [ __ ] yes actually
i was going to talk about this mike
tyson that's mike tyson but i think he
was in an interview and he said i will
eat his babies because he was doing an
interview with somebody and they were
saying like how do you think it's going
to go he's like i'm going to destroy him
i'm going to beat him i'm going to beat
him senseless i'm going to kill him i'm
going to eat his babies
mr spielberg you came back into the room
well i just wanted to
okay fair enough yeah sorry guys i don't
mean to i don't mean to interrupt i just
i i heard you guys talking about mike
tyson and i felt like i did a pretty
good mic typing impersonation so that
was pretty good hey
all right i gotta get back in the edit i
gotta get i got five
hundred movies coming out
well thanks for coming in man
we're always good to see you pal
[Music]
doing the montage remember you had to
break the things over my back and i
remember it hurting more than yes i
remember that hurting you too yeah you
were you had a pat on and it still i had
some kind of terms the thing with my
back hurt
the
glass over my head did not hurt but i
hate that i closed my eyes before you
hit me um you know which was like
and i think they were like i remember
you being bummed about that when we did
it and us being like it's fine it's fine
and i still watch him like god damn it
like you know yeah what are you supposed
to do i mean you know you're supposed to
not see it coming and get smashed in the
head much funnier yeah but what if the
little little sugar glass got in your
eyeballs wow
and you were watching just wipe it out i
pulled that car i remember pulling that
car
yes you did yeah you pulled the car not
that hard though not that hard when a
car is a neutral you can pull it but
you'd think you would be hard and then
you're like oh well it's designed to
roll it is designed to roll and it is in
neutral and uh you know you're not
you're not pulling it you weren't
actually pulling it through snow so
um but it must have felt pretty cool
felt cool yeah
it felt really cool yeah i enjoyed the
ride i enjoyed going for the ride
um
is this the first time we used the
phrase
pop your shirt off
probably i think so yeah that was a
phrase that um i admittedly stole from
two other college buddies of mine who uh
every once in a while would say that um
they'd be like let me pop this shirt off
and i just remember thinking that's
really funny and so we just i just stole
it from them
what are the other people did you go to
college
i went to college with a lot of people i
mean a lot of people went to my college
a lot of people go to college
and i knew the people that were at my
college
and so i called upon them
well also it was a it was an
entertainment uh
driven college so guys let's just say i
went to juilliard yeah yeah no we know
yeah i think we talked about that i'm
sure we have um it's not that
interesting but um
but yeah a lot of juilliard folks in
this and jason van over juilliard katie
chrysler juilliard
i feel like we're forgetting so i feel
like there's somebody there's other oh
sean toomey oh sean toomey sean toomey
yeah that's the clown baby scene that's
the clown baby
yeah sean who we were friends with for
like a year and then he
went yeah he took off he took off yeah
he went he went he was on a pirate
reality show correct and then
disappeared off the factory he moved
back to virginia beach and then explore
the pirates right so in reality he's a
pirate like what is a reality pilot sure
sure sure that's a fair question reality
yeah it's a very fair question this was
right at the height although
yeah survivor like that and so they were
making like new reality type series and
become a pirate and and create some
reality you lived yeah
yes you lived on a pirate ship right and
then the and then you had these various
uh tasks to i guess that were very
analogous to the way it was to live as a
pirate and then you won
yeah
phillips style pirate ship no no no no
no no no we're talking about like
caribbean a black beard
yeah
i'm sure price of the caribbean
yeah uh-huh yeah those pirates yeah so
he did he did that he did that and he
was a contestant on that and
and he and then i don't think he did
that well as i recall i feel like i
watched a little bit i think he got
eliminated relatively early but i don't
remember why which is surprising because
he's a big strong
strapping pirate pirate intelligent as i
recall and uh quite good with his hands
uh good with
how was he with his hook
yeah
fair enough right that's true you put a
hook on your dominant hand yeah you're
gonna have some trouble yeah that's the
thing i remember i was so shown to me
you know i we we would go surfing
together and uh there was this one time
where sean
uh i was at his and zach knighton's
place uh because they i believe were
roommates or maybe zach had moved out at
that point yeah but they were right on
the beach so i used to go to his place
and we'd surf and you know uh eat jelly
beans afterwards because for some reason
that's what surfers do to get the salt
taste out of their mouth
well that's what we did i don't know
anyway um and uh i needed a ride back to
my to my apartment sean's like i'll just
hop on my motorcycle and we'll i'll go
back and and and now i'll admit i'm i
don't like motorcycles i'm not i've
never been on i'd never really i don't
think i'd ever been on a motorcycle and
he's like it's fine
this [ __ ]
like it was like he was in a motorcycle
race
yeah
and i was like sean [ __ ] i don't want to
die i don't want to die from this sorry
bro it's the jelly beans coursing
through my veins yeah i i remember being
really [ __ ] pissed off at him for
for putting my life in danger he's like
dude i'm going 30 miles an hour
he probably was but but he got to 32
it's a motorcycle he got from zero to 30
too fast uh do you still surf
no i don't surf anymore no i was never
very good at it if you look closely in
that episode i was i was looking at it
and going i look strange in this one
part in the underground episode i'm like
bright red and then sean toomey's bright
red and i'm like was that hot in there
and then i remembered that the that
weekend the day before we were out on
the beach
yeah i looked crazy and they tried to
like put makeup on and you can still
tell it's like we're just bright yeah to
me was burned as [ __ ] in that scene
right both of us we look ridiculous the
little guy that you go to fight cracks
me up the guy in the back of that shot
yeah so that's the thing
i really enjoy that we used the uh the
song from the karate kid
um i don't know that that's something
that we would do now but i found it very
amusing at the time karate kid's like
one of my favorite movies it still is
that movie holds up it holds up i watch
it with my kids and love them
fantastic yeah that movie is fantastic
um that song is terrible
yeah uh but i love it um
performed by mr joe bean esposito i
don't believe it was written by him okay
so they were like you know what who
who's the best guy we can get to perform
this awesome song who's the best around
who's the best around
joe bean sure let's go let's see if we
can let's see if we can can you get it
can we get joe
yeah uh he's he's not the best he's the
best that was he's around
he is around he's the best that's around
right now
by the way
that applies to a karate tournament and
receded doesn't it right he's not the
best karate kid on the planet
yeah he's the best that they had around
there was another actor in there um who
was on a television series back in the
mid to late 80s sopranos with no no no
no no no oh oh oh
don
yeah yes done well here's what's even
stranger okay sometimes dan he was yes
okay so he was on a series with our
friend jason bateman right called uh
and so he played um he played one of the
kids in that in that show that's what it
was right and then his name so i looked
it up because i was like i want to look
him up he is credited as don haunts yes
and i'm like oh okay don pump so i look
up don pumps don ponce doesn't exist on
imdb
he just doesn't exist he's daniel yeah
well yes he's sometimes credited as luis
ponce
sometimes he's luis daniel ponce
sometimes he's danny ponce and this time
he was don ponce jesus he tried on don
ponce for one credit and then moved on
from it right or yeah we [ __ ] that up
or much more
much more like he was embarrassed that
he did our show and didn't want him also
fair okay also fair also fair and the
end of your storyline
yes is just you beating him up yeah
that's it
yeah yeah sometimes that's how [ __ ] ends
by the way i wanted to ask you you in
the scene leading up to that where
you're eating the uh
yeah okay yeah the hoagie
you you okay oh right no that was the
seat right when we when we're in there
and we're like you're gonna meet us
there we're like yes i met you there how
are you there and then you go to eat the
hoagie and you cycle through so many
different emotions
thanks man in the eating of that hoagie
do you remember like
like thinking what do you remember
thinking when you were shooting that
because it's such a strange and
interesting choice i think i remember
thinking like how fun it is to just
right completely let it rip right which
is to be like okay
that you don't there's no like
limitation to your choices here because
you're a man out of control of yourself
yeah and then just trying to feel into
each one
and then
being pleased as though i was like oh
that really well yeah i just remember
thinking it was very funny the idea of
like cycling between extreme joy and
like teary sadness yeah uh you know all
within like milliseconds yeah it's i'm a
little bit bummed i've never kind of
gotten to do it again like which is like
what a fun thing to get to do just like
let it go man like what if suddenly you
something amuses you dive right into
that right and then if you feel a hint
of anger for a second chase that down
and then you know there's no feel do you
feel boxed in now on the show no
just in general that would be a very
bizarre choice to do for any sort of
scene yeah
yeah well i don't know if you did it too
many times though
it wouldn't be funny anymore yeah you
did it you did it the one time yeah it
was it was it was special it was special
thanks man i'm proud of that moment
i like it i like it um i'm also proud of
your outfits
and that uh you know with the kangol
house oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
right man i think that's the first time
we put you guys in like funny outfits
right
yeah
yeah probably well yeah well no they
mean the jihad episode we were right but
that was a costume
yeah put on when we were supposed to be
pictures
there's a very stupid
silly joke in this that i i always
thought was really funny and i still
think it's funny i remember it was funny
on the day
uh was that we were boxing trainers so
the thought is ostensibly we were waking
you up at 4 00 a.m to go training and
then so you're you're fast asleep in
your in your room and we're banging on
the door and you're slowly waking up and
the joke is it's it's guys
what are you doing but it's so funny to
me yeah there's no actual clock in my
apartment so i just have to look
somewhere on the wall
it's 11 a.m now was the idea that that
this the the bag of chips and the beer
that's in your hand as you're waking up
was from the night before yeah right
did you wake up in the morning have some
chips and beer and fall back sleep back
to sleep
not sure not determined do you remember
there's a little debate as to whether or
not you were going to bang that rubber
yeah i wanted a metal trash can
and they were like you did yeah yeah
and production was like you can't do
that but i'm like it's funnier if it's
going to crash and make a metal noise
right and we tried to figure out how to
safely do it i was like aren't they kind
of lightweight like wanted like dented
naturally well now what we would do is
we'd go to the props department and we'd
be like we want it to look like a metal
trash can figure it out and then we
would walk out of the room and that
would be the end of it and then we would
show up on the day and if there wasn't a
metal trash can there or one that looked
like one heads
would [ __ ] roll
because we're mean when was the last
time i had rolled on this show we don't
roll heads we're nice what about fights
what about fighting have we talked about
fighting on this show haven't we
i don't think no we haven't talked i
don't think we've talked about like are
you talking about like us getting in
actual fights us as us as the peop as
people not characters fighting in
hundred dollar baby
us as human beings and physical
altercations yeah boys well i know shawn
toomey that was like you were alluding
to this already but he was like known
for yeah just beating the [ __ ] out of
people and i would not want to get into
a fight with him
that was a big guy he's a big guy but
he's also like a he was like an amateur
boxer i'm also happy to say i never
witnessed it i i i wouldn't want to see
that well we were all older
pirate right and also
pirates oh yeah pirates they don't play
by the same rules you know what i mean
oh no he's got a knife in his teeth and
a parrot that will you know the parrot
might attack you parrot's going to get
involved yeah he's going to peck your
eyes out yeah yeah yeah yeah parrot
knows he's going to get some good
crackers and picks
polly wants an eyeball yeah probably
probably wants a finger
i'll say this about the episode going
back to the episode i did i didn't feel
like watching it that we are really with
the show hitting some sort of stride
where we're like well this feels like
a tv show where you know you watch the
first season and you're like wow what is
this what are we doing and then by by
this time i feel like we're we're
finding our own voice
and
i i noticed that we transitioned from
some scenes without any music and i'm
like we should go back to that like
there's some scenes we just like the one
where you're rubbing my shoulders we
just cut into the bar and
there's no like
[Music]
makes it funny so you put music under
that you you [ __ ] it up you [ __ ] it up
i would say in general we score our show
much less than other shows score um
things because to me
it's it's it's sometimes it's a little
bit of a cheat right it's like the
scene's not working we need to put music
in here to make the scene work and now
we do do around
it's amazing how sometimes it fits it
fixes it like where you're working
working a scene working saying like
something's off and then you're like
let's try one of our sunny cues and oh
my god the scene works yeah all of a
sudden it works or you score it with
something else yeah i think we were
resistant to that too because this was
around the time and then that continued
for a few years where like there was
like these big hit network comedies that
were on and it would be wall-to-wall
music right and wall-to-wall would never
to hell you'd see billboards from
everywhere they'd be the new smash hit
for six weeks and then you know some
wacky [ __ ] score just going through
every single scene drove me insane yeah
drove me crazy
yeah so we made it we actually made a
very conscious effort not to do that
as i recall yeah what what
i'm just i i like i like that we feel
we constantly are making a joke about on
this show about how things and this is
based on a bit we did on the show that
we just do do a bunch of things and then
it just sort of ends
and i'm guessing that's how you feel
truly is the the what the podcast is
like we all collectively feel like it's
just sort of yeah you kind of feel it
right over right energy starts to force
it i mean guys we're in we've done 50
minutes
you know we're going to cut 20 minutes
out maybe yeah maybe maybe it's all gold
i don't know yeah i know it does feel
like we start
digging at a certain point but i do no
no i will say though i do want to say
this one last thing like about this
episode to me there's something about it
that does feel like is this i mean
am i wrong in thinking this is the first
time we really kind of
did an episode that really just is not
about a a sort of a major issue
it's just a dumb [ __ ] episodes with
the characters the episode where the
character's just doing dumb [ __ ] well
i brought this up about the one before
where i where i'm saying i felt like mac
bang's dennis's mom was just
about the characters and their
relationship to one another and yeah
yeah and it's not just the last episode
well it's okay he just forgot one thing
that i said but i just forgot yeah just
the one it's just the one thing just the
one thing he was he never let go of the
parking in his mind that whole episode
yeah
i struggled on that last one guys i
really did i was not i just wasn't
really in a good mood i didn't have a
lot of energy and i was i think you're
right i think coming in it i think doing
the podcast at noon is
anything past
10 is really just you know you're
getting you know what we should try uh
we should do one podcast uh well
these have been heavily caffeinated for
you but we should try one where you're
just [ __ ] hammered
we should do one like that well we
should see what happens right
yeah
we talk about that in the oven in this
episode where we're just like well
everything is going to be enhanced with
us being uh drunk yeah get in get get a
little brown in us maybe some brown
mm-hmm yeah
we give a shot sure i'm i'm hey listen
man we should try one where we try crack
and then
try a podcast you know that's what we
should be doing yeah we should have done
some steroids for this one and crack for
the other one we should have banged each
other's mothers
wow the other day yeah
yeah yes yeah yeah you're right charlie
you know and i should have been like you
know what's interesting about banging
mothers um and then you would actually
have something to talk about right like
something concrete yeah they're in their
70s yeah
some sort of thing like that yeah
well guys this has been great and we'll
see on the next one
you